J’ai vraiment pas vu le temps passer.
Attend, mais t’étais où ? On ne t’a pas vu depuis que tu es arrivé !
Oh bah tu sais, j’ai fait quelques balades,
j’ai été visité deux trois châteaux, j’ai fait une ou deux vidéos, un petit peu d’accrobranche pour la forme.
- Et puis j’ai visité le Mont-Saint-Michel aussi, c’était super sympa.
- Ah ouais, ça fait de bonnes journées quand même.
Je dirais pas que le temps est passé si vite que ça.
Après, c’est vrai que j’ai pas foutu grand chose,
et j’me suis pas mal fait ièche aussi.
Globalement, on a déjà tous expérimenté le fait que le temps que l’on ressent est un truc
plutôt variable en fonction de la situation.
Si t’es super heureux et que tu vis un moment de ouf, ça passe super vite.
En revanche si tu es coincé chez mamie sans internet,
chaque minute te parait être une heure, voire deux.
Clairement, on va tous mourir !
Pourtant si on pourrait penser qu’on ressent tous le temps de la même façon,
c’est assez faux.
Chaque culture développe ses propres nuances dans la manière dont il envisage le temps qui passe.
Et bien évidemment, non seulement les cultures influencent la perception du temps
mais le temps lui-même influence la perception du temps…
Pour être plus clair et sortir du comique de répétition, en gros on n'envisageait pas le temps de la même manière y’a 10 siècles
en plein cœur du Moyen-Âge.
Mais comment savoir comment on envisageait le temps au Moyen-Âge justement ?
Et bien c’est assez difficile mais à partir des années 1970/80,
des historiens et des sociologues comme Norbert Elias
ont commencé à s’intéresser à l’Histoire des mentalités et plus particulièrement à la perception du temps.
Et la première chose  qu’ils ont constatée, c’est qu’au Moyen-âge en Occident, on ne peut pas passer à côté du temps
qu’impose la religion.
Le christianisme est en effet omniprésent dans la société médiévale
et il s’est fait une idée bien particulière du temps.
C’est une vision linéaire, et non plus cyclique comme chez les Grecs anciens,
qui est entièrement tournée vers la Fin des Temps.
Et oui, dans les religions messianiques comme le christianisme,
il y a en effet un point de départ et un point final.
Dans les premiers versets de la Genèse, Dieu crée la Terre,
le ciel et le temps lui-même.
A l’autre bout de ce temps qui file tout droit,
il y a l’Apocalypse, la fin des Temps.
C’est le grand Game Over final de l’Humanité avec tri obligatoire entre ceux destinés au Paradis
et ceux qui vont directement en Enfer sans passer par la case départ.
Mais vous allez me dire : attend deux secondes Ben,
les chrétiens ils se sont quand même vachement inspiré des anciennes religions pour monter leur business là,
t’es sûr qu’il y a pas un côté cyclique là dedans ?
Vous avez raison d’insister !
Si le temps chrétien n’est pas cyclique, il est finalement pas si linéaire que ça non plus !
Adam et Eve sont expulsés du Paradis, on descend du divin à l’humain,
puis Jésus, un homme, va racheter les péchés de l’humanité.
Là clairement on remonte de l’humain vers le divin !
On n’est donc pas dans un temps cylique donc, mais on voit qu’il y a de la suite dans les idées.
Les deux visions cohabitent donc et c’est pas plus mal parce que le paysan moyen,
au jour le jour, il vit surtout dans une vision cyclique du temps dictée par la succession des jours,
des saisons et globalement de la vie agricole !
Mais concrètement, comment ça se traduit pour les gens donc ?
C’est une question super importante pour les historiens parce que les derniers siècles du Moyen-âge
sont en fait au cœur d’un basculement entre une perception ancienne
et une perception qu’on pourrait dire un peu plus moderne.
Pour l’historien Hervé Martin en particulier, la fin du Moyen-âge verrait se succéder
trois étapes dans l’évolution du rapport au temps.
Jusqu’au XIIe siècle dans un premier temps, sur le XIIe et XIIIe siècle dans un second temps et enfin au XIVe siècle.
Tout d’abord, jusqu’au début du XIIe siècle, le temps aurait été perçu par les sociétés médiévales comme fixe et immobile.
Le temps était fait de cycles courts faits pour être répétés inlassablement.
Et oui, les paysans, on le comprend assez bien, sont toujours attentifs aux cycles de la nature avec laquelle ils doivent composer pour travailler la terre.
On a donc le rythme de la nature qui s’impose naturellement à tout le monde.
Et à ça vient s’ajouter un temps imposé, celui de la religion par exemple avec des fêtes chrétiennes,
mais aussi celui du pouvoir avec le paiement de l’impôt et éventuellement celui de la levée des troupes.
L’aspect le plus important à comprendre peut-être, c’est surtout que la grande majorité des gens à cette époque
vivent dans un flou quasi-généralisé quand il s’agit du temps.
La plupart des habitants des campagnes ignorent leur âge exact,
le jour du mois,
et même la mémoire des événements qui ne peut pas préciser plus loin que :
« C’était il y a très longtemps », ou
« pendant le règne de tel roi ».
C’est ce dont on se rend assez compte en étudiant les dépositions de témoins pour des affaires judiciaires.
Au-delà de deux ou trois ans, les dates deviennent floues et beaucoup ont le plus grand mal à estimer correctement
les durées qui les séparent des événements qu’ils ont vécu.
Au quotidien on exprime souvent le temps via des oppositions.
Il y a par exemple le temps de la guerre et le temps de la paix.
Le temps du sacré et le temps du profane.
En gros on définit le temps plutôt en action concrètes, c’est un temps plus qualitatif que quantitatif.
Par exemple, si je demande à un type vivant au XIIe siècle combien de temps il va mettre pour réparer ma botte toute trouée,
il va me répondre “Le temps de faire brûler la chandelle en entier” ou encore
“le temps d’aller au village d’à côté”.
Un des seuls repères temporels en zone rurale est la cloche de l’église qui va marquer régulièrement le temps de la prière mais aussi,
et c’est plus important, le temps plus exceptionnel !
Si on fête un événement particulier, si un danger menace, si un personnage public décède,
les cloches retentissent avec un rythme différent, avec une sonorité différente
et la population réagit en fonction de ce tintement.
Ce qui suppose que les ruraux au Moyen-âge
avait une culture sonore assez répandue d’ailleurs !
M’enfin, malgré ça, le temps chez le péquenaud moyen, c’est pas très précis mais on voit l’idée.
C’est un temps “flottant”, mal mesuré…
Les paysans du Moyen-âge sont donc en quelque sorte prisonniers d’un temps confus,
sans contour.
Alors ça ne veut pas forcément dire qu’ils s’ennuient, puisque par définition, un paysan médiéval,
ça travaille toute la journée.
Mais finalement, la seule perspective d’avenir est de répéter les cycles déjà vécus,
des jours et des moissons.
Et vu qu’on a cette notion de répétition, on comprend que c’était une société dans laquelle le passé était d’actualité,
puisqu’il ressemblait quand même vachement au présent.
Ça se ressent par exemple dans les textes de lois du Moyen-âge qui prétendent toujours réaffirmer des lois ancestrales, considérées comme justes.
D’ailleurs à cette époque, même quand on produit une innovation, elle doit prendre l’apparence de la tradition.
Plutôt logique, puisqu’on doit inlassablement reproduire les mêmes actions sans espoir de changement,
autant se convaincre que ça a toujours été comme ça et que c’est la meilleure chose qui soit.
C’est quoi la conséquence de tout ça ?
Et bien on a au Moyen-âge le plus grand mal à imaginer le temps comme une accumulation d’événements liés les uns aux autres.
Ça se voit très bien chez les historiens de l’époque.
Leurs récits, qu’on appelle des « chroniques » sont le plus souvent des séries de faits décousus
qui n’essaient pas de mettre en évidence des causes ou des conséquences,
contrairement à ce que pouvaient faire les historiens romains.
Au contraire, dans le mode de pensée médiéval, les événements n’ont qu’une seule cause : la volonté divine !
Du coup faire un lien précis entre les événements n’est alors plus forcément une priorité puisque c’est dieu qui est l’origine de tout !
C’est un peu comme quand tu as du mal avec le scénar d’un film parce qu’il y a toujours un truc improbable qui déboule
pour sauver les miches du héros et que ton pote, grand fan de l'œuvre, te sort un “ta gueule c’est magique”.
Clairement, on ne peut pas lutter !
On pourrait ajouter un dernier élément qui brouille encore la perception du temps au Moyen-âge.
Vous allez me dire qu'ils ne sont pas aidés mais chaque pays possède sa propre chronologie,
car celle-ci est calquée sur le règne des souverains et de leurs dynasties.
Ce sont donc les successions de générations qui marquent les étapes du temps,
d’où l’importance de la généalogie dans les sociétés médiévales.
Et comme je le disais au début de l’épisode, la perception du temps telle qu’on la présente ici, c’est surtout une perception liée à l’occident médiéval chrétien.
Les choses étaient probablement différentes dans l’Islam médiéval
et plus largement dans d’autres espaces culturels et géographiques
comme l’Afrique, le Japon, la Chine, l’Amérique, etc…
Voilà, on a un bon aperçu du temps pour le paysan du Moyen-âge au XIIe siècle.
C’est...relativement flou !
Et pourtant au XIIe et XIIIe siècle, on va voir émerger un changement dans cette perception du temps !
Les historiens vont constater en effet qu’apparaît une volonté de précision de ce temps flou et flottant qu’on a décrit.
Et ça se voit timidement dans l’outillage avec la diffusion progressive de l’horlogerie,
mais aussi et surtout à travers le vocabulaire qui emploie davantage de termes pour parler du temps.
Dans la langue française, le mot « puisque » devient par exemple un moyen d’exprimer la causalité.
Il s’est passé cela puisque ceci s’est produit avant.
Ouais, ils sont à deux doigts de remettre en question la volonté divine là hein...ou pas !
Et alors pourquoi on commence à remettre en question cette perception du temps, ou plutôt cette approche du temps ?
Et bien ça n’est pas à cause d’un truc en particulier, à vrai dire c’est un processus complexe qui a plusieurs origines
et qui s’étale dans le temps !
Mais on peut souligner le rôle du développement de la bourgeoisie marchande par exemple ou celui de l’administration de l'État.
On va schématiser et utiliser des mots qui peuvent paraître anachroniques
mais en gros les marchands doivent absolument être attentifs aux échéances de leurs contrats,
aux temps que vont durer leurs trajets pour faire transiter les marchandises,
les patrons doivent pouvoir mesurer le temps de travail de leur employés,
les administrateurs doivent fixer des dates limite et des réunions.
Pour résumer, on commence à ressentir le besoin
de synchroniser des actions précisément pour être plus efficace et….
GAGNER DES THUNES !!!
Mais ça concerne surtout la population urbaine et au cours du XIIIe siècle le temps reste assez flou
pour la majorité de la population vivant à la campagne et d’ailleurs
manque de bol pour les patrons,
le calendrier religieux domine toujours et le seul truc qu’il précise bien en terme de temps,
c’est les jours où on travaille pas !
C’est mon épisode, tu m’as volé le clap là.
- Bah vas-y, refais-en un.
- Merci !
Du coup, à la base, j’avais un peu prévu de parler de biologie et de perception du temps, parce que je pense qu’il y a des choses intéressantes à voir.
Mais du coup, personne n’a voulu le faire.
Donc, j’imagine que tu as bien des trucs à dire parce que dans l’épisode, on a dit qu’il y avait des trucs par rapport à la linguistique.
Oui, nan, y a des trucs à dire. Ça fait toujours plaisir de boucher le trous, mais soit.
Moi, le premier truc qui me vient à l’esprit, c’est qu’on parle de temps en linguistique.
Genre, il y a le passé, le présent et le futur. On conjugue etc.
Et on a l’impression que c’est tout à fait du bon sens.
Et que ce serait quelque chose d’universel. Mais en fait, pas du tout.
Par exemple, le futur c’est un temps qui est assez récent. En français et dans les langues indo-européennes en tout cas, le futur n’existait pas en indo-européen.
C’est un temps qui est aussi récent aussi en allemand, en anglais, dans les langues germaniques.
Et donc, il y a une manière évidente d’exprimer le futur, en fait, dans beaucoup de langues, c’est tout simplement d’utiliser le présent. Ou un temps qui est non marqué.
Et d’ailleurs, on l’a encore en français. Quand tu dis : « Demain, je vais à la plage ».
Tu conjugues au présent.
Il y a même des trucs un peu plus WTF, c’est quand tu conjugues à l’imparfait pour faire un futur.
Tu peux le faire en français.
Par exemple : « Deux jours plus tard, il partait. »
“Il partait”, pourtant c’est de l’imparfait, c’est censé être une action passée.
Après, c’est un peu plus littéraire.
C’est vrai. Mais n’empêche que tu peux utiliser un temps du passé pour exprimer un futur.
Donc, ça, c’est assez contrintuitif si jamais on y regarde.
Y a des temps aussi qui exprime l’absence de temps.
C’est à dire qu’en grec, il y a par exemple ce qu’on appelle l’aoriste.
L’aoriste, ça désigne une action qui n’a vraiment ni début ni fin, c’est une action un peu dans sa globalité.
Tu vois par exemple, si jamais je prend la phrase : « La Terre tourne autour du soleil. »
Eh bien, en français c’est au présent, mais c’est aussi vrai dans le futur, c’est aussi vraiment dans le futur. Et dans ce cas-là, l’aoriste, c’est un temps qui serait tout indiqué pour ça.
Mais on n’est d’accord que ce n’est pas vrai.
Comment ça ?
Que la Terre tourne autour du soleil.
Tout le monde le sait que c’est faux.
C'est une blague.
C'est très drôle.
Nous arrivons donc à la troisième étape de la révolution du temps au XIVe siècle.
On vit à ce moment-là le développement et la diffusion d’une invention qui va révolutionner la mesure du temps.
Les horloges mécaniques !
Connues des chinois depuis plusieurs siècles, elles remplacent peu à peu en Europe les sabliers et autres cadrans solaires
entre le XIIIe et le XIVe siècle dans les villes et villages.
Il faut bien voir que les horloges à l’époque sont des machines colossales.
Elles mesurent plusieurs mètres de haut parce qu’on ne sait pas encore miniaturiser les mécanismes.
Des tonnes de métal et le savoir-faire de nombreux artisans sont nécessaires à la fin du Moyen-âge
pour compter les heures avec régularité.
Maîtriser le temps est donc un investissement pour les villes et les villages, mais tout le monde veut s’équiper.
Autant vous dire qu’être horloger à cette époque, c’est l’assurance de ne jamais manquer de travail.
En effet, les horloges sont complémentaires des cloches de l'église, car elles ne marquent pas des heures de prière mais le temps du travail.
Elles sont utilisées par les marchands et les artisans, en particulier les drapiers qui ont beaucoup d’employés, pour déterminer le début et la fin de la journée de travail.
Et paradoxalement, cette innovation qui a permis aux bourgeois de s’affranchir en partie de la mainmise de la religion sur le temps...
elle vient des monastères !
Plutôt rigolo hein ?
En tout cas, ce sont les confréries qui ont développé des sortes de réveils qui frappaient des cloches pour réveiller les dormeurs.
Les moines qui étaient souvent des artisans accomplis ont ensuite perfectionné ces mécanismes.
La demande sociale s’accentue donc rapidement dans les bourgs, et les horloges quittent les monastères.
Ça permet notamment de régulariser la durée des heures,
parce qu’avant l’horloge on utilisait souvent le cadran solaire.
Et le cadran solaire, c’est pas le truc le plus précis du monde !
S’il y a toujours le même nombre d’heure sur un cadran solaire le problème, c’est qu’il y a plus ou moins de soleil en fonction de la période de l’année.
Une heure à cette époque, ça n’a donc pas la même durée en été et en hiver
puisque sur un cadran solaire, les heures sont très courtes en hiver et très longues en été.
Et ça, ça rend les journées de travail très variables !
A la fin du Moyen-âge, les ouvriers des ateliers se plaignaient donc souvent du retard avec lequel leurs patrons annonçaient la fin de la journée.
La mécanique des horloges va régler le problème, puisque les heures font désormais toutes la même durée et tout le monde peut siffler en travaillant,
joyeusement !
On voit donc que l’horloge mécanique fait basculer les sociétés peu à peu vers une perception du temps plus concrète et soumise au calcul.
Ce décompte précis s’ajoute au temps vécu par les paysans, fait de rythmes naturels et agricoles, et va en modifier la perception.
En l’espace de trois siècles à la fin du moyen-âge, le temps va donc glisser, lentement mais sûrement, des mains de dieu, vers les mains des humains.
A partir du XVe siècle, les rois et les plus riches aristocrates commencent à posséder des horloges de chambre,
qui sont une véritable marque de prestige.
Les villes aussi s’y mettent d’ailleurs comme à Prague où la célèbre horloge astronomique est construite en 1410 sur l’hôtel de ville.
Une horloge qui fait encore aujourd’hui sa renommée et qui d’après la légende vaut à son créateur d’avoir les yeux crevés afin qu’il ne puisse reproduire son œuvre ailleurs.
Toujours sympa de voir le traitement des artisans à l’époque !
Au XVIe siècle leur usage se démocratise un peu plus parmi les élites urbaines,
et l’écart se creuse de plus en plus entre villes et campagnes pour ce qui est de la perception du temps.
Les historiens s’en rendent compte une nouvelle fois grâce aux dépositions des témoins dans les tribunaux.
Au XVIe siècle, les ruraux se réfèrent plutôt à des catégories temporelles assez vagues
et souvent en rapport avec des actions concrètes, le temps de trajet par exemple,
tandis que les urbains utilisent davantage des catégories plus concrètes comme l’heure et la date exacte.
La suite de l’histoire vous la connaissez, c’est une diffusion toujours plus grande de la mesure du temps, et avec elle, d’une perception
de plus en plus précise du temps.
Le temps ce n’est plus des trajets ou des chandelles qui brûlent, mais plutôt des heures, des minutes et des secondes.
Le développement du chemin de fer fera d’ailleurs beaucoup évoluer le rapport au temps,
parce même si vous êtes paysan et que vous ne vous fiez qu’à la course du soleil et au rythme des saisons,
vous avez intérêt à savoir l’heure qu’il est, si vous ne voulez pas rater votre train.
Et puis imaginez un peu !
Si vous habitiez à Tours
et que vous deviez aller à Orléans.
Avant vous mettiez 4 jours pour faire 100km, avec l'arrivée du chemin de fer,
non seulement la perception du territoire est bouleversée
mais la perception du temps aussi !
Le temps du voyage ne peut plus être considéré comme une unité de mesure fiable et le ressenti même du temps doit être totalement bouleversé !
Ce que montre en tout cas cette évolution dans le rapport au temps à la fin du Moyen-âge,
c’est d’abord que la technique et le mode de vie sont intimement liés.
En l’absence d’horloge mécanique, impossible de se synchroniser précisément.
Les rendez-vous se donnent à la louche, puisque les gens se déplacent lentement et on ne sait pas vraiment quelle heure il est.
Au Moyen-âge, à moins d’arriver le lendemain,
personne ne peut vous accuser d’être en retard…ce qui est plutôt pratique, on ne va pas se mentir !
Avec l’apparition d’une mesure exacte du temps, puis des moyens de transport rapides, il devient de plus en plus possible, et du même coup, nécessaire, de se synchroniser.
L’horloge mécanique a créé et répondu en même temps à un besoin de précision dans notre lecture du temps.
Aujourd’hui, notre société pousse cette logique à l’extrême,
les heures de nos téléphones sont toutes synchronisées à la seconde près par l’intermédiaire d’internet,
le tout, calé sur la moyenne de l’heure donnée par 500 horloges atomiques réparties dans le monde entier.
Notre expérience du temps a donc été définitivement homogénéisée
pour répondre à des impératifs de travail et de communication.
Et du coup, on se rapproche peut être plus d’un temps que l’on subit !
Cette pression du temps qui se rappelle à nous en permanence par des sonneries, des rendez-vous et toujours plus de choses à faire ou à voir.
On regretterait presque le temps flou et immobile du Moyen-âge. Un temps où l’on était obligé de prendre son temps.
En tout cas si cette vidéo vous a parue trop courte ou même trop longue, dîtes-vous bien que c’est juste votre perception du Temps qui n’est pas bonne, en réalité, j’ai vérifié,
elle est d’une durée parfaite.
Merci à tous d’avoir suivi cet épisode. N’hésitez pas à le liker, à le commenter, le partager, comme d’habitude.
Et évidemment, retrouvez le Vortex sur Discord où vous pouvez échanger sur tout un tas de thématiques, y compris celle-là.
À la prochaine.
Bon bah les amis, moi, j’me barre. Aller, c’est parti.
Attend mais quoi ? On n’a pas eu le temps de profiter de toi !
Ah bah oui mais bon, fallait saisir votre chance, qu’est-ce que vous voulez que je vous dise. Bon aller.
Tu vois, on ne profite pas assez les uns des autres, après on regrette. Faut qu’on change ça.
Ouais mais tu vois, avec Ben, le temps, il passe vite.
Pas comme avec Arnaud,
ou avec Marie,
ou avec Thibaut,
ou avec Manon,
ou avec Léa,
ou avec Florent,
ou avec Florence…